do you member in our first lesson for
algebra I said it would be really cool
there were two kind of ideas that would
be really useful if we developed algebra
we were talking about number one
patterns right when you see a pattern
and it's kind of like true for all the
numbers you goes and there was something
else do you remember what the other
thing was you can turn back in your
books if you prove about the airframe it
could be fue so what do you mean by a
series it could be right or wrong okay
so you're like Thank You statement and
you're like I'm not sure about this all
right yeah so in fact I was kind of what
we were looking at just now yeah um you
might recall how does a row will help us
with this as what we help us with this
but the melodies were okay if I don't
know what the numbers are right like I'm
not sure how many eyes there are in the
room or how many people etc okay I can
still work with those numbers and so we
introduced this new language algebra is
a whole new length yeah yeah okay now
because Adam is a language that's why I
bring this word into our lesson okay
when you do freight or German or Latin
or Japanese or whichever it is right we
routinely translate from one language
into another if you're talking to people
in Japan that Japanese is a better
language to use right we're going to be
converting back and forth between two
different languages today so that you
can be converted in both and one of them
you're very very good at already and
that's words okay so we're going to
encounter like phrases and sentences
just in normal english language but then
i want to convert those into algebra and
sometimes the other way because that way
i can work with them mathematically and
that's really the really powerful so let
me show you some examples that will do
this together so you can see where this
starts off I hope that's big enough for
all of you
let's zoom in just a tad there we go so
can you there we go that's better I
don't sue because what's the center
that's why what a pen okay you can see
where the slide the kids right it says
if a and you'll notice it's italicized
it's kind of leading over like this
that's one of the ways you do that it's
not just the letter it's not just the
letter A it's a printable if it
represents any number so there's our
language of algebra idea and write an
algebraic expression for okay just pause
for a second lots of big words right if
I say to you an English expression or a
Japanese expression all I mean is like a
string of words or symbols or characters
that are in this language right so for
example here's a Chinese expression I
hope I get this right at me Pharisee
don't ask me to write anything else in
Chinese just the only thing i can write
that's my name okay so this is this is a
chinese expression i'm just usually in
this language okay i'm saying something
in that language now have a look at this
see all the beach these are all English
expressions right there verbal
expressions that use words but I want to
turn them into algebraic expressions I
want to use this new language that I've
developed okay so with me if you want to
just write example here on we're going
to have a go at these converting these
words into algebra so if a is my number
right what is three times that number
yeah okay very good you've actually gone
two steps I'm going to write a step
before that three times a but we learnt
last time we can abbreviate that even
more you know if I say I've got three of
these whiteboard markers it'll be the
same to say i have three whiteboard
markers so we kind of leave this tires
out and we just right 3a now let me
point out here the first reason why we
like doing this which is more concise
this or that it it's a clear one right
this is a lock wicket of life and so if
I want to work with this number whatever
happens to be it's gonna be much better
to write this rather be constantly say
three times that number three times that
number and have to write that out that
would take me like a good 15 20 seconds
to write at least if it's going to be
legible for you okay so that's what
three times that number is tell look of
a next 13 less than that number oh so if
I number would say 10 what would be
three less than that number seven if my
number were like say 105 what would be
three less than that number 102 okay so
you're always starting from that number
you're starting from that number but
you're what operation about doing here I
am yeah
i'm subtracting i'm taking away like
three less then that number do you see
that you can put in if you thought about
what what if a was 10 10 take away 3 is
7 like you told me before so this is
much quicker and more seats are a level
3 that's not normal how look at the next
one the next consecutive number you see
is a bit of a bubble here in case you've
never seen of the word consecutive it
just means the next one just one after
that okay so if a is my number what's
the next one yeah a plus one fantastic
seven to get to the next one you have
one to get the next one yeah I'd one you
guys are getting quite good at this okay
the number multiplied by itself yeah Bri
oh ok excellent a times itself and then
I can go another step and be even more
so sick yeah fantastic ok so now when
you see this you can read that as arm I
know what that means that just means
whatever the number is and I'm multiply
it by itself ok or on the home stretch
feedback to what we're looking at all
and square roots and cube roots before
the square root of that number how do i
write this yeah yeah I have a whole new
symbol for this right so that's what the
square root symbol looks like and where
is the able on yeah just just underneath
right there we go that's the square root
of my number hey and yeah ok now great
question if I wanted to be super easy
you know precise and not ambiguous I
could write to hear because where we see
cube roots before you'd write a three
you can actually take fourth or fifth
and sixth ribs if you wanted to the
reason why we do tend to write it to
bear and I'm okay if you don't write it
to do is because when you're doing this
square roots are by far and away the
most common type of operant that we're
going to do with so when you don't see
one there we can assume this too ok last
one one further that not
one third of it yeah ok so now this is
interesting there's a few different ways
I could write this ok so I'm going to
start with this I can say one third what
what operation is of like I cited it
three of these or five of these which
one would it be yeah I don't she's
giving got to be read a third of
something right now I can then go ahead
and write this in other ways right I
could uh I could put that a on the
numerator that would be true but I also
know that the fraction sign is kind of
like another way of writing division do
you see that so all these ways just like
in English I can say the same sentence
means of different ways right and mean
the same thing I could say hi I can say
today say hello it's a how are you which
might not even be a question but just a
way of reading you ok just like it out
on the right there's lots of different
ways or valid that you can use does that
make sense ok now these are all pretty
simple but you can use this anytime you
see words you can translate them into
algebra and then it makes it easier to
work with ok